Charles good morning how are you I'm
great brother how you doing I'm doing
okay
where do you think we're headed with the
coronavirus when it comes to canceling
games or games without fans well I'm not
sure where we're at I hope we don't get
to that point to be honest with you my
question would be if those fans don't
come to the game are they just gonna
stay in the house forever are they gonna
go to work are they gonna go to dinner
like just because they don't come to NBA
games or sporting events or we assume
and they're just gonna stay in the house
for the rest day like yeah it's a great
unknown no I mean I know I know but
that's the thing that's interesting
about this whole debate like okay they
don't come NBA games they don't come to
college games but I take the pejorative
those people don't still go to work or
go out in the world so they still gonna
be half the virus circulating I mean I
think we just got to be have some common
sense I mean like I say if they don't
come to the games are they gonna beat
like I said they just go stay at home
for the rest of their life but I think
these leagues are I think we're gonna
have games without fans coming up I
think my gut feeling and then I wonder
about March Madness and the Final Four
the fact that they're already thinking
about canceling the Olympics or
postponing the Olympics you know well
they should they shouldn't cavalry and I
think they see mudal
Olympics to the United States because
we're because you know some people Dan
that's their whole life the Olympics and
it wouldn't be fair to those people
who've been training for basically the
last four years they should move into
United States we already got all the
stadiums you know both of those
countries build new stadiums and stuff
that that becomes an eyesore in history
if you go back and look at what thing
the United States we can do la we can
just Chicago we can do in New York we
already got all the stadiums built but
there's people who whole life revolves
around the Olympics and I just don't
think it would be fair to cancel like
even we boycotted the Olympics one time
that really wasn't fair to
lot of people who like I said the
letters are really big deal to certain
people talking to Charles Barkley
hall-of-famer Turner Sports NBA analyst
where do you stand on the MVP race right
now is it isn't a race that's over not
over LeBron is gaining but Yanis got the
lead in the clubhouse
you know what Center is LeBron has
played great but then ask you a question
who was the leading scorer against the
Bucks Friday night for the Lakers and
the leading scorer for the Lakers Sunday
against the Clippers Anthony Dennis okay
just checking
you would not know that by all these
these passes on television hey LeBron
has been great LeBron has been great but
I was like wait a minute I know LeBron
has been great but and I understand
there's that Kobe narrative the LeBron
plan for the Lakers
you know everybody want to be
sentimental and that's understandable
but from day one this year you know this
has been the best player in the world
they're on paid they were on pace to win
70 games and LeBron plays with Anthony
Davis that's that's a big deal and it's
interesting I hear some of these foods
and clouds and jackasses get on TV and
said well Yanis plays in the week of
Eastern Conference
I mean you mean like LeBron would he won
all his MVPs and he played with loaded
teams Bosh Dwyane Wade Kevin Love Iren
Kyrie so I'm curious if you can frame
the narrative how you want to Dan but I
just don't think it would be fair Yanis
has been the best player from day one he
doesn't play with Anthony Davis LeBron
has been amazing but I understand all
these guys you know they want it they're
like okay LeBron feel angry at 35 act
like he's 100 up and say dude that way
you know he's 35 I'm like 35 give me a
break but I just hope I just hope that
people use their common sense yeah but
we love a storyline the media loves us
storyline they wrote yeah you're correct
but you don't get to create your
storyline your storyline is Yanis is
going to like I said before he got hurt
they were gonna come really close to 70
games really close he's playing with
Chris Middleton who's an all-star
LeBron's clan with Anthony Davis is
probably one of the top five players in
the world and then like I say they say
well
Yanis plays in the East I'm like LeBron
when y'all were bragging all those years
he made it to the finals he was playing
in the East so like you said you yeah
you're right the media wants to change
the narrative and make it what they what
it is what they brought in just my
opinion your honour's has been the best
player from day one in the NBA this year
I saw where you're going to auction off
a lot of your memorabilia why now you
know it's just you know I was talking to
one of my mentors Billie Cunningham and
he was he was gonna sell his memorabilia
cuz you know your kids don't want that
crap and I don't want to be 70 years old
having people hey let me show you my MVP
trophy I mean I don't want to be one of
those old guys that happened a long time
ago and my hometown needs some help
you know I was down visiting my friends
in the last couple weeks and my side of
town is not great and I think that I got
an autograph deal with panini and the
guy said he can get a lot of money for
my MVP trophy my gold medals but my
daughter I asked her cuz he's the most
important thing I said do you want this
stuff she said I'll take a gold medal
and you can auction off the rest and I
got a lot of good stuff I got a flag a
United States flag signed by everybody
on the dream team as I stole from
Barcelona it's what it's one of the
coolest things it was laying around it
was it I grabbed it and I got everybody
to sign it's actually on the wall at my
house I got a lot of really good stuff
and then I don't need that stuff you
no it's sitting around the house because
actually around my mother and
grandmother house they both have passed
away and like I said it's gonna be great
for my hometown because it needs some
work
what can i buy then you can't afford
anything probably that I got curious if
you had something you know like I got
the Dan edge to that we can kind of pull
our money together and I could buy some
today yeah you know what you know what I
apologize I you know what you probably
are loaded all that long as you've been
in the television business you probably
are still you are loaded because you
know what you probably and I'm give you
a compliment you're in the conversation
for probably the longest person who's
been on television on major networks I'm
trying to think look in the conversation
with you I mean you might be you might
have one of if they're one of the
greatest careers ever but between you
being on other networks and having your
own thing now you've had one of the
longest career as ever
well thank you no I mean that's that's
incredible I'm kind of comedy how about
your dating Flyers they look pretty good
I I wish that they weren't getting this
much recognition that makes me nervous
they're a little too hot right now well
you know I hope that a young kid over he
wins a Player of the Year
I hope Anthony Grant wins the national
coach of the year because they've been
great yeah
I've been studying them for the last
couple of months man they got a shot
there's no great team there's no there's
probably 20 really good teams it's up
for grabs
I think Kansas are probably the favorite
but they're not a strong favorite
because Dayton Gonzaga Baylor I thought
Bailey might be the best team but
they've lost three out of four but I
think I like to say it's going to be the
best without the coronavirus in the
conversation
this could be the best
battle for the n-c-double-a tournament
ever because of all the upsets now
you've had a great career in a long
career and to Hall of Fame careers as a
player in a broadcaster but I was sorry
to hear the draymond Green is going to
take your job I don't know how soon
that's going to happen but is that this
year next when does draymond Green
because he's not gonna be in the
playoffs this year but is your job safe
my job
you know I dant draymond Green is a nice
guy
I like dream on and he's a good player
but you know what he is he's like the
guy in the boyband who's the least
important number if he think he think
the crowd is like cheered for him he
doesn't realize he's standing next to
Justin Timberlake yeah he's the least
famous person in the boyband and he
thinks he's a star so he's Joey he's
Joey Fatone I'm not gonna talk about
jewelry I know Joey okay Lance Bass he's
lances but he's like in the boy band
who's lucky to be in the boy band and
like he think all the girls are
screaming for him and like no they're
screaming Justin Timberlake you're just
in the band and you're being in a band
because you never gonna have any hit
singles but that's but he was a nice guy
I like messing with him I do I like
messing with him but he first of all he
you don't have a face for TV he's got a
face for radio so he's not gonna get
mighty big year would you trade your
career for his career no my career is
what it is I was a great player I didn't
win the championship but there's a lot
of guys who didn't win a championship
are much better than some of these guys
who get championship rings man my career
speaks for itself I didn't win it you
know I always find it fascinating when
people want to try to shoot you down
they say you didn't win a championship
you know it is a team game it's a team
game but also some of these guys have
got rings they would just own it
some people bus they were bus riders
they would both drivers and it does come
up it feels like that's when somebody
goes scoreboard on you when they go a B
and never won a championship and I
because they act like you're playing a
poker or something and when they're it's
like one day like I got nothing else to
say but you didn't win the championship
I'm like okay I got that what else do
you have
it's like if they act like we're playing
tennis I was like you got no
championship that's game set and match
I'm like okay I get it
I didn't win the championship is that
the only thing you've got you know
always laugh because I'm like yeah okay
I think everybody know I didn't win a
championship if that's your final point
you have like any more points and they
don't have any more points because like
I said man I take everybody know I was a
hell of a player I didn't win a
championship but you know nobody thinks
draymond is bad meal karma law or
Patrick Ewing or Elgin Baylor nobody
think that who's got any common sense
but I don't hate all three months he's a
good little player and he's a nice guy
when are you know I told you though he's
in the is in the board man he thinks
he's Justin Timberlake and he's not when
are you going to start selling off your
sports memorabilia do we have anything
to promote here where people can find
out more information on this you know
what did I tell you what I'll do I'll
let you know cuz right like I'm in New
York now I got to do Colbert tonight
within you yeah then March Madness start
Sunday and so I'm crazy for the next
month and then I go right into the NBA
playoffs so nothing's going to happen to
right out for the NBA playoffs and what
I'll do is then because you've been
great to me all these years
I'll come on your show when I when we
get everything set up and announce where
people can go a bit on this stuff
that'd be great we had Christian
Laettner on last year and he admitted
stealing stuff from you during the dream
team well we were all stealing from each
other because I got some Michael Jordan
stuff I got a Mike I got a Michael
Jordan practice jersey a warm-up I got a
magic Johnson warm-up I was feeling like
it was loading every every game I was
stealing stuff that's a separate mo
action on but I stole a Michael Jordan
practice jersey I warm up and I got a
got a magic also so a lot of stuff gonna
come up them guys been looking to be
bidding on his own warmups
you know what I should do it I should
try to sell it to them first
I don't know I'm Jordan be interested in
buying but magic might wanted it's gonna
be great man I'm excited I'm really
excited about that have fun with March
Madness we'll catch up with you again
and always appreciate you joining us hi
my brother you take a few guys take care
that's Charles Barkley beyond Colbert
coming up tonight we'll take a break
play of the day is coming up next on a
poll question as well and a couple of
stats of the day coming your way right
after this